like it doesn't even matter like do you
think that that's a because of the kid
that kind of helped you reprioritize
what's important well um
yes and no yes uh because the way our
relationship was headed
uh we were already gonna break up so
like how many years in like eight
nine years in i think at that point we
like our relationship
was so [ __ ] up that it was like okay
we either fix it or
we just [ __ ] dissolve everything we
we leave jk we [ __ ] get rid of
barbell
in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain
podcast this podcast is full of corona
in this room right now
we have the source himself wuhan bart
what are you
talking about i am the source of the
vaccine
this [ __ ] face right gave 14 people
honestly it was like seven or eight i
think this
[ __ ] [ __ ] all of us up and i
decided to bring in the source
uh everybody was tested before they came
in here so we're all good yeah we're all
cheers to being negative
cheers cheers to being negative for sure
we have the alt so if you guys are not
familiar with who bart and geo are
because there are a lot of new listeners
um hi everybody hello bart is the sole
owner of this company called barbell
brigade hey that's okay
and his assistant geo
right here next to us i hate you i'm
leaving podcast over
so bart you guys i mean if you've seen
joe on this podcast so bart and geo
own a very very successful powerlifting
company also a part of
jk films jk news and many other
adventures such as
jumbi matcha which we're also a part of
yup so this is who the [ __ ] they are he
also
is the source of covet the
vaccine i gave tim the vaccine steve the
vaccine david the vaccine
heard the vaccine i was so pissed at
this [ __ ] because i'm like i'm
doing everything right how did this
happen how did this happen i don't know
where i got it from
yeah it's been pretty nuts because like
we weren't doing anything i could have
like i don't know pump gas and it was on
the gas thing and i picked my nose and i
put it myself i don't know yeah you
really would touch your face after you
touch a gas pump though
i don't know well the reason why we were
all so surprised is because we have my
mom who's a senior that watches
she probably gave it to me she hasn't
had it because we all probably gave it
yeah so we were like completely [ __ ]
scared because i'm like holy [ __ ] this
is my mom so anything
prior to that we were so careful yeah
like we would see people and like we
would get them tested
and yeah we just didn't want to give it
to my mom so then when he was like i
feel sick
immediately i'm like holy [ __ ] we gotta
get tested like immediately it's kind of
crazy too how fast that stuff spread
like i i definitely am
even though i have like the antibodies
now right like i'm still
i'm even more cautious than i was before
which is crazy
just because like how quickly you can
get it is how fast you can get it to and
also how the information of kovi keeps
changing absolutely
because it's evolving now so i'm like oh
god like i just
i don't want somebody to go through what
i went through because it was so bad
like i
remember we were talking about like the
hip pain and the back pain was the
weirdest part
yeah so i think like when you're
confined to a room you don't realize how
much
you actually move throughout the day so
even like walking to the bathroom
walking over here or just doing and
being active
so i was just sitting pretty much either
on my computer
or watching cobra kai and that's it and
then so i would start sleeping and i
would get this crazy hip and back pain
and then it would hurt to the point
where um it would hurt in the middle of
the night when i'm
moving around and then it actually
affects sleep but i'm like what the hell
is going on there's a few days where i
couldn't go to sleep because the my back
was hurting so bad and my hips were so
tight
and then you're also because of the
headache that you have
i can't even like stretch it out or like
do like shadow boxing or something
yeah so i'm just kind of stuck finding
this weird position where i'm
comfortable
and when i find the spot that's when i
knock out and then if i move it starts
to ache again it was
my hips were killing me like pulsing
yeah how was it for you because like for
us too right so he got it first
uh when we tested he he had it and then
i tested negative
and then i want to say like a week into
it i had a scratchy throat but that was
about it
and i thought the scratchy throat for me
was anything yeah i was just like okay
well the flu is still
i'm sucking his dick you know you don't
get [ __ ] stop it
stop it um so like i where i sleep
knocking on the door
why does it sound like a fish is
drowning in there
save the fish uh where i sleep it's
right by the vent so like i thought the
air was hitting me so that's probably
why i had to scratch your throat
and then um i got my hands on some like
rapid tests
so then i i tested and then i became
positive too
that's the only side effect that you had
yeah just to scratch your thoughts that
was it it was wow
lucky i'm mexican you know i was also
crazy though because when i was in
quarantine i was in the
in my room and i didn't see her and so
she would bring
food up to my table with gloves a
[ __ ] mask knock on the door
and then when she clears the hallway
that's when i would open it and then
eventually she gave me my own like
dishwashing detergent
so after i ate my food i'd wash it in
the sink before i even returned it to
her
so we had a really clean protocol and
somehow you still caught it yeah
probably just the uh your symptoms
maybe just came late maybe you had it
but it just came out absolutely i think
that's what it was because
mine came pretty late too it was like
eight days after yeah so it was super
late
because i tested negative three times
after you told me that yeah so i was
like oh
after the third day they say test
negative i did four or five after that
and i was still negative
and then i felt a little funky and i'm
like
i'm not so i cancelled all my [ __ ] i was
like i'm not seeing any
houses no house tours for for renting or
whatever and i stayed home
and then when i uh you stopped by to get
the test it's when i took it and then i
was like
uh oh i think i got coven for sure and
when i went to the hotel
i ordered a fat burger double double
patty everything i was like hey
i'm in this hotel by myself guess what
your boy is going to [ __ ] eat
whatever the [ __ ]
is like your version of masturbation i
like it and i was going to jack off too
as i eat the burger hell yeah so i was
like
you know
and then break it in half and eat it
afterwards no you idiot i was saying
that your version of masturbation is
food i don't want to hear about you
masturbating
jacking off all the time oh god and then
i eat the wing it tastes a little bland
i'm like fat burger sucks i ate the
second wing and i'm like
i don't taste it at all oh [ __ ] it just
started disappearing one bite at a time
first night
i had food it just disappeared at the
moment i tasted it right when it went
away
so i ate one wing it was like kind of
bland second wing completely gone
and i'm like damn it was my worst
nightmare i'm like
i i just got jacking off now that's it
and that's whack
so i was like okay what the [ __ ] you
should try to taste jizz to see if you
could taste it
no i know that should have been the time
to try it no i did the the hot
chip challenge thing oh it didn't work i
couldn't say [ __ ] i could feel the pain
on my lips but i couldn't taste anything
wow
my [ __ ] tasted it though that [ __ ]
was [ __ ] burning like a [ __ ]
but
i literally couldn't taste anything up
for
uh two weeks it was no taste around week
three
i could kind of taste so actually that's
a lie
day seven i had a little whiff of
something and i actually cried
a little bit i teared up shut the [ __ ]
up that's how important it tastes
yes i told you that i would literally
give up sex for the rest of my life if i
could still keep my taste
what a hundred percent i think i might
be on that boat too my man
what's up right here 210 pound bar now
what's up okay wait wait let's
okay let's all close our eyes okay let's
think about how ball my [ __ ] is all
right david are you with me
dude david god damn it okay now think of
that the best sex we've ever had and you
know that she's [ __ ] bombing you know
when she was quiet and she had her mouth
shut
that's awesome you know what you
[ __ ] suck you're never on my [ __ ]
side let's see if you get it
any time soon yeah but see if i imagine
this all right here we go
imagine like the best sex that you've
ever had with any woman that's not
just me just and then right so you have
that right but then also
imagine never having that again now
imagine the best meal that you've ever
had in your [ __ ] life and you never
get to have that again
which one would you rather oh that's
tough but you got to go home with me
let the man speak all right my wife all
right
now close your ears now tell me the
truth okay tell them the truth the pasta
okay jokes aside because obviously i'm
[ __ ] around but really what would
your answer be
sex or oh that's really tough i don't
know
that's so that's i mean that's like
almost saying like go to jail right
because you can't have sex in jail at
all they have sex in jail but the [ __ ]
oh okay that's so tough i don't know
yeah back [ __ ] is that what that [ __ ]
is
yeah that shit's crazy i don't know and
stuff you you have to answer though i
have to
of course what the [ __ ] like you find
it's like either you would be here
[Laughter]
it's like you can think of your answers
all those good ass foods that you've had
it's all gone now and then but you get
to have amazing sex
or whatever she offers oh i think it
would have to be the food
it's got to be the food food you can eat
multiple times they have
bob breakfast no i guess i get it this
isn't going to be that much
the spiders you would even give me away
for that i love sniders
that's like my favorite road trips now
that's like trash baby and you just gave
me
up for trash dude this [ __ ] is not
worth snyder's dude
the level is so [ __ ] low hey step
your game up dude do some kegels or
something i don't know i do
all of that [ __ ] i do all of that
whatever he wants
i do it love i mean because for you
taste is whatever to you right
taste is important to me yeah thanks for
[ __ ] splitting up our marriage
oh please you already know he's gonna
choose food my man knows the difference
between regular coke it's mcdonald's
yup look at this i'm always surprised
how much he can eat
why well because even if people who are
really above
like i see them eat but he eats an
absorbent amount of food like it's
actually kind of ridiculous
how much you can eat you actually can
eat more than me i think so but i look
like [ __ ]
so i don't understand you can say that
for the people in the back
you be quiet here all right he clearly
doesn't enjoy the [ __ ] so
you see what you gave him you gave him
ammo what about i'm going for what
i just see this fool just going like i
said who are you looking at not my wife
that's not sure
that's exactly the french fries honey
mustard pretzels
so i found out through this random
online article i was like i always look
up like random food [ __ ]
and i was finding out what makes
mcdonald's taste so good and it came out
so years ago he has been saying
that mcdonald's coke smacks way better
than everybody else's [ __ ] and in our
minds we're like dog it's just regular
[ __ ]
yeah you tripping and he doesn't know
[ __ ] about food however
this article specifically denoted that
mcdonald's has a specific formula for
their coke
syrup that's a little more sugary than
everybody else's stuff
and he knew the difference between
regular cooking mcdonald's coke and he
even knew that ketchup is specific to me
since day one because i always i get
coke
extra ice i can even i can just imagine
right now you hit the button
the [ __ ] he does too wait wait wait wait
if you see get to the almost to the top
right click
and then you go like this you let the
eye settle so you do one more time
now you get the coke and it goes up
when you put the thing on and then you
put the mcdonald's straw which is
thicker than the other ones and stiffer
for that mouth feel
you put it in and you sip on it
or the most he's not [ __ ] around
things in the world
now describe now describe my [ __ ]
her [ __ ] and how you would make her
come because i stick it in and dancing
yeah yeah that's just so crazy
no one time um so this is how serious he
takes his [ __ ] mcdonald's and i
was like i was in disbelief i'm like
this [ __ ] could not be having a
[ __ ] pouty pouty time
because howdy powder yeah so this is
what happened so sometimes they forget
right mcdonald's [ __ ] up all the time
they forgot to give him the straw oh
[ __ ]
exactly so then i'm like sorry yes hold
on
yes that reaction was ridiculous for
this for this story
oh shh because that's what the night
field is that's what happened
oh you know he's having a [ __ ] heart
attack i'm like we have a bunch of
straws like
we ordered out all the time so we have a
[ __ ] ton of straws yeah everywhere
ruins the coke yeah and he would not
[ __ ] drink it we had to go back to
mcdonald's to get a [ __ ] strike
donald straw the one with the red and
the yellow one
did you did you like read up about it or
you just know this i just knew it like
when you put it in the mouth
it has different sizes and the way it
comes in
like the the syrup it just tastes way
different dog i will ask this food like
where's tyga he goes i don't know
he doesn't know anything but you know
the intricacies
that's the crazy thing like i i assumed
that you would have read something about
this no but
everything he said is true it's wider
the straw is wider and the material is
thicker too
yeah he found out after he's like i knew
it i knew it i knew i could taste it and
i'm like that's
the ketchup [ __ ] nuts when you take
like let's say you go they go do you
want ketchup and now i'm gonna catch up
at home
if you use your heinz ketchup it's
different from the ones in the packets
way too useless dude that's the most
useless piece of information i've ever
heard in my life
you were talking about this earlier
where the reason why i so i literally
just texted his full no context
about how right he was about this stuff
because i was cracking up we had this
junebe holiday party where we were taste
testing new recipes for shrimp daddy
and these are new recipes when you when
you're in the r d process when you make
food for these concepts
most likely the first batch that you had
is not going to be that great and
arguably so it wasn't that good me joe
we're eating it we're dissecting it
we're like yo uh it's just not hitting
right it's not that good and i look at
bart's face he's eating it like it's
[ __ ]
bomb and [ __ ] i was getting seconds
and then you see where bart looks at us
he goes oh yeah it's not good at all
it just keeps eating i'm like dog what
the [ __ ] are you talking about
but he knows the difference between the
thickness of a straw that the mouth feel
of [ __ ] coke
ketchup it's nuts this fool's a [ __ ]
human raccoon
he eats [ __ ] trash man anything a
[ __ ] raccoon's down a dude this guy
does it and he enjoys it it's trash i
don't know if it's a chinese jean or
something
but there's something about like you i'm
down
if i eat something nasty right i know
it's obviously nasty
but i'm still down to complete the food
all the way to if it's bomb as [ __ ]
so i don't know so i think because of
that my i'm willing to try
nastier [ __ ] and nastier [ __ ] isn't as
nasty as other people say
what in the [ __ ] is wrong with you
you're kind of like mario like i've seen
mariel eat like spoiled food multiple
times what the [ __ ]
i've never done that stuff so mario you
have i have a story
okay he's like that's disgusting you're
over here what the [ __ ] are you
i'll tell you what the [ __ ] he fed me
fine i'll choose your [ __ ] over
snyder's
no too late it's too late so mariel
she has this like that immigrant
mentality too like specifically that
she's gotten from her grandmother so her
grandmother
when nobody really goes by the
expiration date you usually go by smell
yeah like
i only go by the expiration date okay
well excuse me two weeks too early
so like there's sometimes like mario
would uh like i would open up something
in the fridges and tupperware i'll pop
it open and i'll smell it i'm like yo
this is gone bad and then mario's like
in the back she goes
i hate that for breakfast oh [ __ ]
did you smell it she goes it tastes
defined to me i'm like bro there's mold
on this
did you grow up eating moldy bread or do
you cut the mold off or do you well i
originally did but then i i looked up or
a science teacher told me that that's
not how mold spores work
once it's on there it spreads everywhere
so you're eating the spores no matter
what part of the bread it's on so i
stopped doing it
i grew up just like cutting the mold off
of it so now i know
okay so my story now so this
[ __ ]
uh we had we had ham okay schneider's
i mean your [ __ ] said
people are just gonna start calling you
sniders it's okay they'll never die
um what was i gonna say okay so so uh
because he's the better cook between the
two and he always has creative ideas i
let him take it away
and one time there was this ham and he
ended up cooking it right
you know what i'm talking about i'm not
gonna thank you you're trash
okay so he cooks it he gives it to me
and then um
and then i eat it and i'm like cool this
was this was great thank you so much for
cooking the next day
i was looking at that ham and it had a
bunch of like little bumps on it because
there was still some left
yeah and i'm like wait is this the ham
we yesterday he's like yeah i'm like
this is bad oh it's pork belly the pork
belly had bumps all over
it yeah and then i'm like this is bad we
shouldn't be eating this this is bad he
goes
no it's all right i washed it all off
i'm like what the
[ __ ] i can't did you have diarrhea no i
did you throw up no i did it exactly but
you [ __ ] habitual line stepper who
made that up who made that up here
i feel like somebody didn't did you did
did you care about your family no he saw
[ __ ] bumps said
i did the first step i go oh it's not
bad okay and we know his nose is broken
by that that's true
and i rinsed it and i was able to scrub
the bumps off
and i'm like all right time to why would
a meat be
normal to consume if it had bumps on it
you go ask the meat i don't know
that's [ __ ] funny dude i don't trust
it there was no mold on it
there's [ __ ] bumps which is a version
of this color
protein smells when it when it goes it
immediately smells sour
it didn't smell sour but you have a
broken nose that's tracking
how many times have you eaten rotten
food i don't know anymore
no wonder you're so strong you know
right the one to coronal only gave you a
slide
it's like i've eaten rotten food for 12
years straight that's all i've been
doing
yeah yeah that's what the [ __ ] this guy
does to me like everything every move he
makes
i just have to like brace myself you
know like i might die today
like if he drives he drives like [ __ ]
i'm like i might die today when he cooks
i'm like i might die
the better driver is he the better
driver driver a million percent
depends on who's paying attention though
if i'm paying attention i'd drive not
too bad
he's really bad but i rarely pay
attention what do you mean if you're
paying attention
why is that a stipulation well because
like i think i have like crazy 80d
and then so like if i'm actually trying
to drive then i think i actually drive
pretty good
but most of the time i'm like oh what i
wonder what what they're thinking about
and then i i need the other cars to go
like this to make me know to go like
back in my lane
hey don't ever drive taika to school at
any time i pay attention when i drive
okay no he doesn't he doesn't yeah
he drives the way he talks right so if
he's talking fast or loud then he's
moving at that speed
uh if he has to think then he's actually
like stepping on the brakes to like
gather his thoughts and i'm like what
the [ __ ] are you doing we're on the
[ __ ] freeway like you can't do this
[ __ ]
that was my dad though when my dad would
i would always hate pissing him off in
the car because if he pissed in the car
he's driving fast he'll drive
super [ __ ] fast just like cursing me
out in korean and he's going like 80
miles an hour like
zipping through the [ __ ] traffic used
to scare the [ __ ] out of him what's the
craziest [ __ ] he ever did
when he was pissed that's not those
there's too many he threw a office chair
at my head once
no no while driving oh sorry well my mom
i remember she's done this a couple of
times actually when they would get
fighting cars my mom would always be
like
drop take drop me off right now or i'm
jumping out of this [ __ ] car
right my mom is screaming in korea just
let me off right now so my mom one time
i [ __ ] you [ __ ] not
my dad's like you want to be dropped off
right now we're on the freeway she goes
now
screaming he goes fine he goes parks the
car on the front and my mom gets on the
freeway and starts walking
on the phone on the side of the road my
dad drove off
of course like a real man does and he
just drove off right
and then we get a call we get a call
from the cops
saying um because she uses her phone
call or whatever one night she goes
i'm sorry say is this your mom or your
your wife or something like that right
and i'm like
is this my mom is she where did you find
her right she was like she was walking
on the side of the road on the freeway
and we have her at the walmart oh my god
and i'm like holy [ __ ] dude how [ __ ]
embarrassing so my dad had to go pick
her up at a walmart because she was
caught walking on the freeway because
where my dad left her
i don't know why i picture your mom with
[ __ ] disheveled [ __ ] [ __ ] up
hair
[ __ ] leaves coming out of it dirt all
over her face dude
dude i've told this story multiple times
but my mom i've literally caught my mom
because she's angry at my dad she has
her secret hiding spots
which by the way we don't have a big
house there's not much places to hide
so eventually we start finding these
things usually it's just the garage
right couldn't find her one night and
then the uh
we we thought she was gone forever
because i don't know where the [ __ ] she
went
and i see something like rustling in the
in our backyard and i see something
coming out of our pumpkin patch
there's a little pumpkin yeah [ __ ]
pumpkin our backyard is huge so there's
like this squishy gross squash and
pumpkin oh cool this [ __ ] comes out
she has like 30 mosquito bites on her
face it looks like braille
she slept outside in the dirt oh my
in the squash patch that's some [ __ ]
kills she wanted to piss my dad off yeah
just
she spied of him and then she just comes
out like killmonger from black panther
just dots all over her face
[ __ ] she was a spiteful spiteful human
being so if she
if she wanted to incite a reaction out
of my dad she would go to the [ __ ]
extremes
did she get one or your dad already left
for work oh my dad was like that would
have been fun
my dad would say stupid [ __ ] too like
i'm like 22 years old at this point this
is not that far ago right
i'm like 22 years he goes i have to find
you a new mommy i'm like
dad i'm 22. like i don't need a newborn
the [ __ ] are you talking about
but he would get fed up with a lot of
our antics because it was so extreme in
our house
like i remember i love it if you go into
our house i could show you every single
hole in our house
from a wall being punched from somebody
throwing a rice cooker from my dad
kicking the door down
dude it was [ __ ] violent in our house
dude your dad a pastor he is a pastor so
he was trying to exercise the demons out
of her heart
okay which my mom was [ __ ] nuts and
when i look back at it now
yeah i actually understand my father a
little more because this [ __ ] woman
is nuts
as a kid as a kid you were more scared
but then now you're like oh she's just
because i'm like dude i'm surprised my
dad stuck around
oh she's kind of crazy like she
incites anger out of people well not to
other people but specifically
yeah we know our man's buttons you know
what i mean so we're like then why do
you do it
should we okay
yeah so my dad like it's so funny too
because now my dad cracks up because he
says like oh now you understand i was
like i do understand now i do understand
why you were so stressed because
my mom is somebody who's hyper emotional
and now that i'm older i can have
conversations with her and tell her
hey you're being a little ridiculous
like when i went back for
uh last year thanksgiving she was trying
to make this korean dish so she was
asking for a large bottle of vinegar
right my dad was like oh i'll go get it
he comes back he gets a medium sized
vinegar
this [ __ ] she goes off she goes do you
not know what a large size bottle of
vinegar is
what the hell is this i asked her i was
like hey what the [ __ ] the problem
and she goes i wanted a big one i was
like can you still make the dish with
the small one she goes yes
you can't even drive how [ __ ] dare
you damn yeah i was like how dare you
yell at somebody for getting you
something that you can't get yourself
yeah be quiet yeah she goes mommy crazy
she just goes back to making kimchi oh
god
yeah that's the type that she was able
to kind of like get like snap back into
reality she's like [ __ ] it
well i mean that kind of sucks right
because there's such a big emotion for
something that's not that important to
her
yeah so it sucks because now she just
stressed out david
the dad and it wasn't even that big of a
deal because she's like okay
do you know how i feel now excuse me
what
are you like you just called my [ __ ]
[ __ ]
i don't know if it's all girls but i do
feel like you know when you see like uh
just the way dads and moms take care of
kids
the moms are always freaking out over
the smaller [ __ ] and i feel like maybe
that's just something that's just
maternal or something maternal or native
to stupid asses are alive
because we're looking at all the
possibilities about vinegar
i don't do that do i do that
i think so i think all chicks do a
little bit let me ask you something yes
do you on a on a regular basis how often
do you try to chastise or correct
something that he does on a daily basis
i think i've eased off a lot you have
eased off a lot actually
a lot a lot um so not too many i mean he
still does a bunch of dumb [ __ ] but like
i try to let that go
yeah i think you should have something
else absolutely you do dumb [ __ ] all the
[ __ ] time like what
like um one of them is he'll turn the
water on to wait for it to get hot right
and i uh he knows that i hate wasting
water so he'll leave it on
and then he goes and takes a [ __ ] that
always takes him at least 10 minutes
at least and i'm like why do you even do
that like why why would you do that you
know time it out
so once it gets hot i could jump in the
shower take 10 minutes it's like five
minutes
exactly it takes five minutes for your
water to get hot yeah we got this stupid
[ __ ] tankless ass water heater
thingies like it's these small ones so
it just takes forever for us to get hot
water
so it's supposed to be newer and like i
guess mo
more eco-friendly but it's actually how
yeah i don't know how because you know
like the traditional water heaters
the big cylinder ones like they're
already filled up with hot water so it's
instant
pretty much instant these ones they have
to heat the water and it takes like five
minutes for it damn
yeah and i know this is a stupid example
but that's the only one i can think of
but he's always doing
dumb [ __ ] how do you guys resolve that
stuff that you just kind of
just let it go well he's really good
because um either i let it go
and i'm like okay this is [ __ ] dumb
and i would just like not say anything
or he just listens and he's just like
man whatever like
we're at the age and at the point in our
relationship where we pick and choose
our battles
we're just like i'm being on both ends
yeah yeah i think it's like is it worth
getting riled up or can we just let it
go yeah what's the real thing we're
trying to do if we say we're trying to
watch a movie later
then whatever happens in between let's
just get to our asses on the couch
and have the good time that we said
we're gonna have yeah and then
everything else
doesn't really matter how long did it
take for you guys to get to that point
though okay so we're 12 years in
damn um and i think the last two or
three years have been like
the best like the [ __ ] best don't
last more than 10 minutes
or even 15 minutes i think now we're so
in sync and we're so on the same page
that we just want to have a good time
so regardless of like who felt like like
who wronged who
would just go back to the kitchen or
living room look at each other just hug
it out like it doesn't even matter like
do you think that that's a
because of the kid that kind of helped
you re-prioritize what's important
well um yes and no yes uh because
the way our relationship was headed uh
we were already gonna break up
so like how many years in like eight
nine years in i think maybe
at that point we like our relationship
was
so [ __ ] up that it was like okay we
either fix it or
we just [ __ ] dissolve everything we
we leave jk we [ __ ]
get rid of barbell we split ways um or
we [ __ ] muscle it out and we talk
about literally every single [ __ ]
thing and fix it right then and there
um so that was like the first catalyst
to like really dissecting and looking at
our relationship and then once that was
getting better
we were like okay i think we're in a
really good stable place to now bring a
human into this world
and then i think uh once we got pregnant
i hate that
we once i got pregnant we got pregnant i
got pregnant all right i did all the
work
um no no no i swear it was all me i said
the plants without the seeds ooh dude
that's poetry right there dude
especially with that hat on that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] hit way harder
it was tight
you saw dust come out i was like oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you can't have the plant without the
seeds though yeah we can we're in
[ __ ] 2021 we don't need men for
anything
this is very true um yeah so then at
that point we were just like
what the [ __ ] is important you know and
like he grew up kind of like in like the
type of environment you did where there
was like a lot of hostility
and our relationship was pretty hostile
for a few years that i'm like i ain't
doing that [ __ ] and bringing a kid into
this world
to witness that [ __ ] and um yeah he's
just really good at like
being super logical with [ __ ] and just
going like yeah i need to cut that out
that's so interesting because like i
feel like that's
that's a hard part for people to do as
they get older because when you get
older
you're kind of more set in your ways and
not really willing to change
i i disagree man i think like that's
just lazy
i'm saying most then most people are
lazy when they're older
because then you hear people that are in
their 30s going like oh i'm too old i
can't [ __ ]
yeah those people also look like [ __ ]
they they look like the way they behave
yeah and those are the people that will
be like i'm sitting my way away so you
can't teach an old dog new tricks it's
like shut the [ __ ] up like you can
always change some [ __ ] if you really
want to
having a kid though i think actually
helped me understand her
so that helped me out a lot where um
like i'm super logical right
so things have to make like
very um like logical sense and it has to
go like a to b
b to c and that's how i understand
things but when it comes to emotions
like you can
experience all kinds of things at the
same time yeah like one it's like taika
going on to a white board going like
this yeah
it could be like you could be pissed but
then also cry because you're kind of sad
but you also have empathy or you're
happy
you could feel all that and it was
really hard for me to understand that
and then also um uh the way that she
expresses things
like because i'm logical like when she
she's mad at something
and then it hits my like my logical i
guess like
dominoes it goes ding ding ding ding
ding by the time it hits z
i've also exploded but because she's
emotional it's fleeting
she lets it out it's gone right but for
me once it hits z
like i have an atomic bomb that goes off
inside my body now i'm pissed for at
least six hours
yeah so by me like taking care of taika
and seeing how he is he can be happy and
then sad like literally within seconds
it helped me understand because like
kids are so amazing i like how
i before we continue this podcast let me
talk about one of our amazing
sexy ass sponsors we're talking about
raycon earbuds if you are
listening to headphones with wires in it
well
aren't you a dummy because you should be
listening to the
best audio with the best
earbuds with the best best audio quality
you have ever heard in your life and i
love my raycon earbuds because i don't
have to deal with wires i don't have to
deal with wires while i'm doing jumping
jacks
or chasing after somebody that stole my
rice krispies treat yesterday
yes i tackled that three-year-old and i
took my rice krispie back while i was
listening to a podcast
in your face a couple of stats about the
raycon earbuds they are water resistant
and sweat resistant and
they pair up seamlessly with bluetooth
i don't want to deal with stuff with
hassles and raycons do not have that
listen up my friends raycon's offering
50 off all their products for my
listeners and
here's what you got to do to get it go
to buy recon dot com
brain that's it you'll get 15 off your
entire recon order so feel free to grab
a pair
and a spare that's 15 off at buy recon
dot com slash brain
by recon dot com slash brain because of
taika you can figure me out
no because kids are like a child
expressing all this emotion what i
learned the most about it is
he has nothing against me right like we
have no beef he it was just brought to
you you don't know that
well that's what i'm assuming and so
what helped me
is not taking your emotions personally
now yeah whereas before
like something that she would explode on
i would take it personally like you know
i hate when you act like this
when you go crazy and now i go that's
just the way she has to express it yep
just like how taika is going to express
it that's really hard to do
yeah and it took a long time but i think
having the kid was helping
help me able to take care of the big kid
well i mean and we would also talk about
it a lot because for
people just sneak this to her ass and
she was tight what'd you say
[Laughter]
god dad you guys please don't call me
that it's already done that honey
mustard i'm already trying to geo
snyder's [ __ ] hey some people are
really gonna want it now yeah but it's
all over the place so it's cheap and
easy go ahead
yeah uh what was i saying what did you
sneak in what did he say
that's a big kid that's all she said it
took the little kid to understand the
pictures yeah pretty much
pretty much but like because he didn't
grow up with so much emotion like
any emotion was huge for him you know
like even if it's overwhelming yeah like
me just going like oh [ __ ] i stepped on
my shoe like i scuffed my brand new shoe
for him it was like
me going oh why didn't this happen
you know but i think for the regular
person it's like oh [ __ ] i know that
feeling
you know so for him it was just like we
were all completely any little bit of
emotion that people
expressed that was like negative it
would like
it was almost like people were sobbing
as if like their parents died or
something
it was crazy really yeah has it always
been like that for you yeah
[ __ ] yeah no it's been tough so you
couldn't even
see like the spectrum of emotions nope
it was just
i could see it but it's just so
overwhelming and it almost like
paralyzes me
because i'm like holy [ __ ] i've never
experienced you know like when like
like let's take that with the most
emotional latina ever yeah it would be
like
like even when i can't believe you got
it with a [ __ ] mexican girl dude
like even if i get a car accident with a
friend right when we're in the car
accident and like let's say we're about
we hit a car and we're spinning out of
control
if we're spinning you started writing a
journal as your car yeah basically
no if we're still composed if we're
spinning um
i'm of course i'm like in fear because
the car is spinning but if someone
goes oh [ __ ] then all of a sudden
my entire attention is drawn to that
overwhelming emotion
and almost that emotion is bigger than
the car spinning
i just picture that accident happening
you go stop being a [ __ ]
yeah pretty
[Laughter]
yeah he says it takes him a minute like
even if like someone were to hit him it
takes him a few seconds for him to
register the pain
you know you know what is wrong with you
that's what i'm saying
you know why it's because you were
[ __ ] dropping e at the age of six i
think so
you [ __ ] up your head so much you did
so much drugs way too early dude
yeah it could be more it could be the
crazy buddhist upbringing where
everything's super suppressed
you're not supposed there's too many
there's too many things here there's too
many things too many people i think
that's also what drawn me to e
was i think when i was 14 or 15 yeah i
took ian i was like oh
[ __ ] i could finally feel for once hey
friend
hey friend he's like hey remember that
time i called you a [ __ ] when we're in
that car accident
mid accident i'm sorry yeah yeah i feel
it now too
that's it he's come i mean we've
obviously as a couple
have come such a long way and i i think
our relationship's so beautiful now
um do you feel that you had to learn how
to be less emotional
uh when interpreting what he's doing no
because it was really cool because
he was now so now we're able to
understand how we each communicate
so when he gets super logical before i
was taking it as
damn you're not respecting you know like
i'm emotionally bleeding
right now like you're not taking into
account how i might be feeling or even
trying to understand it or question it
you're just trying to get to the bottom
of the [ __ ] issue and i'm like i'm
bleeding right now like please take care
of that
guy like we also know somebody i'll say
the name after the podcast but
he's also somebody that i had to talk to
recently about how he doesn't
understand that not everybody needs
their problems fixed because nobody
[ __ ] asked you to fix their [ __ ]
problems right
and i think his biggest issue right now
is that he's learning at a very late age
in his life
that what he says that he wants out of a
partner
is actually not the person that likes
who he is like so for example what i
mean by that is that
in his mind he's saying i want a girl
who's a boss ass [ __ ] that knows what
the [ __ ] she wants
she makes good money and i don't have to
make decisions for her and i laughed at
his face and i was he was like
why are you laughing he's like that's
what i want i was like that's what you
say you want but that's not how you
behave
i'll say because the problem is is that
you're somebody that likes to fix
people's problems
well guess what when a girl doesn't need
your [ __ ] help to fix them he's
useless
where is your conversation going yeah
you talk to people you don't
you don't speak with them yeah you go oh
so this is what you should solve this is
what you should do
yeah i was like girls who have their
[ __ ] together they don't need you for
that yeah they just want you to
be your own boss yep but you start
feeling an ego
thing where it's like oh you feel less
of a man now that this woman knows what
she's doing yeah so how do you want a
woman like that
yeah what i mean so he always tries to
logically give people
all this advice and [ __ ] when it's not
really necessary that's why women like
that don't like you
yep so you got to figure out what you
really want yeah you're not wrong
um so so yeah so we started just
understanding how each other
communicates and thinks and we really
stuck to respecting that
so i didn't have to tone it down and he
didn't have to tone it down because now
when he comes in with all the logical
[ __ ]
when i'm feeling emotional about it and
i can't get logical then it's like hey
right now this is kind of too much
let me figure it out we'll talk in an
hour so now he knows i like the space
thing a lot yeah
the space thing helps a lot [ __ ] yeah
you know so now like he knows when to
expect it and he's not just like in his
feelings going like [ __ ] when are we
gonna solve it we're gonna [ __ ] we got
we gotta talk about it
and then at least for me i'm not gonna
say some hurtful [ __ ] because i'm just
super emotional i don't know how to
express myself and i just i'm gonna
[ __ ] cry or yell or whatever
yeah yeah what they also learned at a
late age which is pretty crazy
so i say i'm logical and i know i'm
logical but i think as a human being
you're
still just emotional no matter what so
when we get into a fight
and then right away i want to talk she
needs to feel it and collect her
thoughts
yeah when i say i want to talk i really
don't want to talk i really just want to
argue
and have this logical battle of trying
to convince her why
i'm wrong and i'm right but that's not
really trying to reach
each other and get to a compromise or
really trying to hear each other out
you're just trying to
prove your point and it took me a long
time of actually her like asking me
questions so i'm trying to have this
they're calling me out and figuring out
these logical battles
when i was able to finally you know what
i'm just gonna take her word for it when
she's
gonna go chill the [ __ ] out i'm gonna
chill the [ __ ] out too and when i'm
chilling the [ __ ] out and i'm kind of
venting to myself and having my own
dialogue
once i got all of that out of the system
when i went to go talk to her i'm like
oh [ __ ] i actually don't need to prove
my point and i'm actually really ready
to hear what you have to say and it was
just kind of like my logical was just
being masked by having a very emotional
articulate argument but it really wasn't
logical i was still just as emotional
i just didn't even know i was it was
dope because like the moment i i caught
that that was happening
i felt like neo of the matrix because it
was like we were both heated
we both thought we were right at
whatever we were arguing at so he's
going like i'm just trying to be logical
i'm just trying to talk blah blah blah
this and then he's trying to prove his
point and i was like i saw zeros and
ones
yeah i did and i was like like i just
started
like i giggled a little bit because i'm
like oh my god i can't believe i just
cracked this because i could just hear
him
and how hurt he was and it was no logic
at all
it was pure emotion and i'm like oh [ __ ]
you're really sad right now right i'm
like damn is it because of this this and
this and he's like
yeah and i'm like yeah you're not being
emotional i mean logical
yeah and then i went like this i started
running the other way
oh [ __ ] she figured it out she figured
it out it was nuts
because a lot of the arguments don't
even have to do with oh
it was it was epic and then once we were
able to really see that that
it's like our own perception of whatever
happened
and it's obviously with the baggage that
we have that we're perceiving these
things as incorrect or whatever
and then all we're doing is just [ __ ]
throwing negative emotion at each other
once we were able to figure that [ __ ]
out we were like
oh that's really hard though all this
stuff is so [ __ ] difficult and i
think like
you know for for a lot of young people
who listen to this they're like oh now i
know what to do it's like no
it's a lot of work you're gonna try it
and you're gonna [ __ ] fail not saying
you should
keep trying it but it's very difficult
it's something that you have to keep
on trying because this is like a 12-year
relationship yeah so it took me like 35
years to figure out
when i say i'm logical i'm not really
being logical yeah
did you just kind of believe who you are
and it took all of that for me to go oh
[ __ ]
i'm actually just venting and i'm
thinking that i'm
being logical but i'm not and then so
now when she takes her time when we get
into a fight i take my time
and when we come back in 15 minutes it's
way better and that's why none of our
fights really last past 15 minutes
yeah that's [ __ ] crazy dude it's dope
it's really dope
i can't i can't fight with somebody and
then go to sleep that's my problem
that's tough it has to resolve
like mario's person like she'll [ __ ] up
my whole day and then two hours later
and i'm just staring at her like instead
of a [ __ ] yeah that's how we work
how you just sleep you stupid [ __ ]
and i'm over here
oh wait till 7am in the morning and she
just wakes up
do you feel better i'm like look at my
eyes i haven't slept
you know she could sleep through
anything like she she could be pissed
and then snore the next hour i'm like
[ __ ] how how does this happen
you sound like us who's the one that
sleeps uh
about being angry before me yeah like i
could i could
have sex i could eat i could do whatever
like i'm fine
again because i'm used to feeling all
these types of emotions like i feel
happy sad angry all in like a matter of
like compartmentalizing like oh this is
my happy space
cause like whatever i'm feeling consumes
me
like entirely that's why i don't yeah i
guess it is per component it's kind of
hard for me to ex like
experience two emotions at the same time
cause like let's say that we were about
to meet with
with david to shoot this podcast right
yeah and we got in the biggest [ __ ]
fight ever yeah
as soon as i see david you're out of my
brain hey what's up man yeah let's
[ __ ] shoot hey what's up everybody
yeah still be pissed yeah you know yeah
you know
uh you got me in trouble once because
uh maryland he didn't really do anything
but marion it was one of these moments
that you had so marielle and i were kind
of lightweight arguing or something
right yeah and then you facetimed me
right oh yeah and then i started
cracking the [ __ ] up and she looks at me
she's like
so you were just all upset and then bart
calls you and you're
giggling your ass off you know i'm like
but it's burnt you know and then after i
hang up i look i'm like
all angry and she's like what the [ __ ]
like you're so happy to talk to
everybody else but bart calls you and
you're laughing your ass off hey stop
flirting with my husband you
jerk i'm uh hey man he says you're your
pussy's like snyder's
he needs some other type of joy in his
life yeah a little salty too crunchy
it's okay they're not for you anyway um
but yeah man i
i think uh i think doing that type of
work really is
though not you working on your partner
yeah cause then that's never gonna do
[ __ ]
it's really looking at yourself and
going wait why did i get triggered by
this wait why do i care about
him leaving the toilet seat up wait why
do i care that he didn't wash it when
you guys felt like
your relationship was falling apart and
that option was on the table to like hey
we just should just get rid of
everything and then start doing then we
go our separate race yeah did that scare
you a little bit
yeah because i didn't want that yeah
yeah cause this was the first time that
we had to look at our relationship
because when we first got together i
think we were
honestly boyfriend and girlfriend for
maybe a couple months and then after a
couple months we became business
partners
and oh [ __ ] yeah we just became business
partners i took over
and then we ended up being like pretty
much more business partners
we spent more time being business
partners than being romantic
romantic because and even when you go
home in a start-up business you're
always troubleshooting and figure things
out yeah
so all of our conversations are very
it's just like all day long business
talk and not so much like our own
intimacy yeah and then if we had like if
we weren't having sex enough or we
weren't being intimate or romantic
or having dates like that was okay
because we were young we were like in
our twenties and it's
[ __ ] we wanted to hustle you know so
it's all about your whole mind it's like
we could get that stuff later absolutely
you know so all these little things we
just kept sweeping under the rug
and eventually you can't walk on this
rug anymore because there's so many
bumps and you're tripping and you
[ __ ] hate the rug and you want to get
rid of the rug
that when we were gonna break up it was
like [ __ ] but i really love you a lot to
unpack too
yeah it was rough man and like and it
was like no
like i really love you and like he
really loved me and and it showed how
devoted we were to each other
it was just we never took the time to
really appreciate it
yeah so at that point it was like well
okay let's decide are we gonna leave it
or we're gonna stay and then we were
like
okay we're gonna stay okay now what do
we do [ __ ] we gotta
talk every single night for like months
to just unpack and unpack and it was
exhausting
like would you did you could you even
imagine after like
10 years of being together and you're
single again like
how the [ __ ] how fun i'm just kidding
for me it's almost been seven years
right yeah and i'm like and
the thought like let's say mayor and i
split right then i think about
how do i how do i
you know go back to being flirtatious
and you know
trying to spawn can you flirt with me
what is that like hello
no really what would you how would you
flirt i honestly don't know like to be
honest with you that's
that's the thing i don't [ __ ] know
how to flirt because i
i think like before it's like innately
in you because you don't have anybody
attached to you yeah so when you're
attracted to somebody
you're just trying to spit gain yeah now
and you're just in that phase
now i'm not in that face i don't even
know what that's like it's like hey
what's
your name he said my name is a david
said like a kid he's a nice
what do i do you know because like
because for me too prior to that
like i i'm just sweaty thinking about it
right now like i'm freaking out
because i don't know yeah i don't know
what i would do i know how to be
friendly nice but i don't know how to
flirt now like in terms of i'm
physically attracted
to look at her tits and then we get it
we like it
i don't know what to do because before
it was through humor right yeah and then
humor was some
i'm missing that piece where i don't
know what i did after it's like
i would make the person laugh and make
them comfortable yeah now my mind goes
blank after
i'm like well how do i like close the
deal i don't know what i would do either
because that's what i'm saying i'm so
used to like having like a wife and
talking to a wife
i might just play hey can you make me a
sandwich
you just go straight just grab her tit
yeah what's up
that doesn't really work like that guy
yeah that's what i'm saying it's it's
we don't ever think about the the part
that just is a given now because we've
been together for so long
like what is the the courting etiquette
here like what can i do what can i do
what could and i start to get anxiety of
this i'm like oh [ __ ] like do i
do i even know how to be a single person
and i don't think i do when i see my
friends that are still in the dating
face and i hear the problem that they go
through
it's like almost like an entirely
different world i'm like
oh [ __ ] it's like that where like oh
they said they're gonna call you back in
four days but they did it so now you're
worried
and i'm like trying to relate but i
almost forgot what that felt like and
they're worried that
they're because she's such a given in my
life that she's like
half of my life right so i can count on
her on everything i can count if i wake
up in the middle of night there's no
doubt
there's no doubt she is in my world yeah
so when i hear stuff like oh i don't
even know what to do after four days she
didn't call me back she told me he's
gonna call me back
i'm like i don't know what to say
i'm like hey man that sucked yeah that's
all we got it's like damn that's uh i
think it's harder for you guys because
you guys are males so it's kind of like
a given
girls are easy like it's just i just
have to show that i don't have a ring on
anymore
and it's like girls it's like this is
their dude and there's like 12 other
friend zone dudes that just yeah they're
waiting up there they said
the [ __ ] up right yeah because for guys
like we have to try yeah we have to try
like we don't look like daniel henny you
know what i'm saying like so it's not
no one's going to mistake you for him
don't worry oh it has happened multiple
times
like are you daniel heny's [ __ ]
dumbass brother yeah yeah okay
yes that is me yeah yeah but it's it's
it's weird because like i've only seen a
couple of times where i've seen a guy
get approached
like a woman gets approached oh wow and
you know they're
very very attractive i see like
specifically there was a girl on
instagram that i was following right
let's go find his [ __ ] right i'm like
and i got a big fallen
but i don't i'm not like trying to sign
under dms or whatever right
and then one of my other buddies very
handsome guy absolute nobody he goes oh
she's hot i'm a follower too
balls her she dms him right back she
goes hey how are you and i'm like
you and i are no longer friends like you
don't talk to me ever
like she'll like my stuff because i'm
funny or whatever but never dm me
and he just exists and he just gets
whatever now i got to know these people
after
so like even like so another buddy i'll
tell you his name after right i'm pretty
sure he doesn't want me to tell the
story so i won't
tell you a name too so let's just call
let's just call him his name is peter
right so peter
this dude has literally messaged me
multiple times
about what he should do while he's on a
dating app while he's talking to these
women and i have never
ever in my life had women say certain
things to him
ever right and he's a really really
chokhan guy like really nice guy
so but he has like a bad boy look to him
so girls kind of are attracted to him he
has tattoos like
he's like this nice like tan dude
tattooed up [ __ ] sexy looking as hell
and on the app i [ __ ] you [ __ ] nut he
sent me a screen cap of his conversation
and i got so infuriated because he
couldn't close the deal only because he
doesn't know how to interact with this
even though it's a given
so he writes the back and forth she goes
hey i think you're really [ __ ] cute
and he goes oh he goes that's the most
straightforward [ __ ] i've ever seen
that's what i'm saying
[ __ ] and you know what he writes back
you shut the [ __ ] up i got a story after
that god
damn it so he writes back he goes he
goes type that's cool
sounds like bart and i'm like okay dog
so what happened and then so she's like
so he kind of just kind of like doesn't
know what to say and i'm reading this
text thread right
he goes she goes okay she goes hey i'm
gonna be in your town you want to like
hook up
hookup means [ __ ] yeah right yeah and he
goes he goes that sounds tight is what
he wrote back
i'm what are you doing just close the
deal right
and at the end she just writes what do
you want me to do
to you i've never ever had a single
woman
talk to me like this ever
right and he just writes back he goes i
don't know
question mark and then the conversation
dies
and he goes i don't know how to close
the deal i will [ __ ] murder you right
now dude
all you have to say is what do you want
to do to me whatev he could do whatever
the [ __ ] he wants to win all he had to
do was put his picture up on a [ __ ]
dating app and they just like the way
that he [ __ ] look in his vibe
but you already know what the [ __ ]
happened to him so he was trying to get
at this like really cute white chick
back when he was in ucla um she invites
him over to his apartment because she's
gonna have a get together
oh yes and there's gonna be like a pool
party get together oh
so she says she was really pretty she
was like really really pretty
um and then so he shows up and then she
goes
and they're in the pool right at this
point we're in the hot tub in the hot
tub and then she goes
yeah i don't know what's happening to
all my friends some of them showed up
and he's like oh man that sucks
i was like i was like your friends are
so irresponsible
right it's like she's like literally
throwing herself right here
she's sitting right here i'm sitting
right here and the entire pool was all
empty
on a rooftop and then i i was so
oblivious
that i was like your friends didn't show
up i'm like
damn that sucks like your friends are
just that flaky i didn't read that she
wanted me to have alone time but she
just didn't want to make it awkward and
go hey you want to come swim with me
i hate you because she's like i'm having
a pool i don't [ __ ] hate you you
probably said like well
let's reschedule this party probably
something like that
oh my god what would you think you
didn't think that she wanted to like
hook up or not i think there's
maybe like a ten i got another one too
there might be a ten percent
like thought but you're like impossible
but it's like yeah it's impossible
okay so then he was dating this is when
we were friends obviously so now he's
dating like this foreign exchange chick
who's from like
uh oh austria yeah yeah pretty
pretty tall uh slender she could be a
model
um he i don't know what happened that
she was asked if she could sleep over
so they sleep in the same bed this boy
okay good night
turns over doesn't do anything i'm like
what the hell i'm a judge
what's wrong with you you [ __ ] that
girl
probably felt like she was the ugliest
person on earth yes
like hideous yes he did that it's
it's actually kind of hard for a girl in
my personal opinion to kind of put
themselves out like that
yes i would so when we were first dating
too i would wear like his t-shirts with
like nothing underneath or like a
like like his uh muscle shirts that were
longer because he's like bigger
you can see like side boob and stuff and
he'd brush his teeth and he would just
go to bed i'm like what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you i'm [ __ ] hot
what are you doing so responsible didn't
do laundry
you're like you know it's winter right
you put on a [ __ ] sweater
basically i'm like are you gay or
something do you
not see me do you not see this right
here
yeah but later i come to find out very
bad laundry habits
you just put a [ __ ] hoodie on her
yeah what's wrong with you yeah you're
going to catch a whole [ __ ] cold you
know
um but later i come to find out like for
him at least
he just grew up in a very religious
household so it was like all very
shameful
but with your friend i don't know but
like religious people though they're
like the freaks though
i could go either way them catholic
girls dude they're [ __ ]
nuts they could go either way though
they're just looking for nut in their
face all the time
they're like who's gonna knock in ye
face
uh one of our mutual friends we went to
one of those like youtube celebrity
basketball games yeah yeah yeah
and you know like as dudes you almost
never experience what
like hot chicks go through or even
regular chicks go through right
and so uh the memory got there they had
a briefing in the lobby and you could
just see
one of the other you cause this guy's
good looking you can see one of the
other
um uh like youtube chicks look at him
and just immediately lock eyes and when
you lock eyes you're like
oh [ __ ] that's really forward because
girls don't
let you know like you know like i i [ __ ]
i'm down to do whatever damn what's it
like to be good-looking and then
i'll tell you later the whole night um i
didn't really pay attention
but then uh this guy who's closer to you
than he is to me he's like bart
can't shake her i'm like oh i think i
know what you're talking about and i'm
like what he goes
like give me the eye signal and i would
look and wherever he goes the whole
night
on the bus going to eat the after party
wherever that chick is always following
and then i think we had a one hour break
the next day
he said i'm gonna go back i see everyone
later i'm gonna go back to my hotel i'm
gonna just chill a little bit and then
she goes can i come and then he's like
don't you have your own hotel room oh
jesus
cause i think he wasn't trying to oh but
it was just crazy that
that girl that dudes some dudes are just
so good looking that girls can't even
control themselves that girl literally
showered that night in her room with
her clothes on crying crying crying it's
like i literally opened my legs and
threw my vulva in his mouth
yeah and he went that is what he did he
said schneider's or whatever
he says schneider's not even that
[ __ ] i like schneider's opinion oh
snyder's
honey mustard pretzels that's [ __ ]
crazy
yeah when you see people with that
certain level of attraction it's kind of
crazy how much they can
that's what i'm saying like good it's
even true i think statistically like
people who are better talking about
good looking people as if like i'm not
in the looking dudes oh okay
we're talking about dudes right now
which you should understand as well yeah
so
i do have them isn't it true like
statistically like people who are better
looking actually book more jobs
absolutely 100 they did a study with
like uh
with babies and they put babies in a
room with a
not so attractive person they didn't
want anything to do with him
as soon as an attractive person came in
they were like drawn to them
yeah that's true one of my friends has a
really ugly baby
and i hate that child for no [ __ ] way
no wait the other way it's the other way
around
oh what the baby's supposed to like not
like unattractive people oh really well
i hate that child
that baby but when i look at him like
yuck dude you're so disgusting
that maybe it looks like e.t that's why
but i'm not most babies look like
most babies are pretty ugly like taiko
was really ugly
okay this guy has way more of my genes
than jio's yeah that's for sure
and then later on he got way better
looking i thought tycoon was pretty cute
when he was born people
[Laughter]
i was like either this baby got a hold
of
a lot of my genes or geo is just all
playing when he was first born
they look icky like when they're first
born they're like gray and kind of weird
looking
no but like a few hours later he was
what the [ __ ] what's with your face
i was just picturing him when he was
born was ugly he was cute no tiger's
gonna look at this one day like
[ __ ] you dad nice kids we love him so
much he wouldn't even care he's cute as
hell you know for you
um when you had taika right and with
tigers now what almost
three noises three and a half about
almost three and a half he's gonna be
three and a half in march and then four
in september right so he's almost with
three or four years old right
so uh i had a conversation with a friend
of mine
and i didn't understand this at the time
when she was saying this to me i thought
it was kind of dumb
but now that i look back on it i
understand what she's saying now she
goes uh when i have a kid
like i think i would hate it when
somebody calls me whatever my kid's name
is
like let's say um baika let's say oh
that's baika's mom
instead of saying my actual name right
and i was like why do you
why do you care about that i think she
was talking about you kind of lose a
little bit of your identity when it just
goes into the child
and so do you feel like for you like
when you became
a mother that you had to go that you had
a trouble like finding
yourself as a woman or are you okay with
just
being this kid's child um i'm okay with
being the kid's child but
what happened was kids mother i'm sorry
the child's mother yeah my bad kids
whatever
i have a child oh [ __ ] and i'm sober
completely but
that's how [ __ ] down i am that i
still went with it um
yeah i don't mind being this child's mom
at all
and if they call me tyka's mom i love it
i don't care but i think in the
beginning it was rough for me because i
had given
so much of myself to taika like
naturally you should
that i'm like oh [ __ ] wait who am i
anymore because like my body was
completely different like i wasn't
sleeping i wasn't eating right like i
was just so
focused on a side note though as as just
to diss this [ __ ] girl we're out in
vegas right
she's telling me what her body went
through after pregnancy and i could
literally give a [ __ ] less
she literally looks at me right as fat
as i am
she goes dude do you know what my belly
feels like she's like touch it i'm like
that's what my stomach feels like don't
you ever [ __ ] complain to me about
your problems and i was like talking
about my feet
i can't tie my shoes because my belly
yeah
i'm like are you talking to like 30
years of my life right now bro like what
are you [ __ ] talking about
hey now i know now i know what you go
through you know heartburn
yeah it was [ __ ] rough it was rough
heartburn
all of that getting hot out of nowhere i
was getting like gasped out of nowhere
just thinking i was already [ __ ] i
couldn't breathe
but um yep all you mm-hmm no but like
yeah the first
the first couple of years i was just
like this guy
this dude this dude is christian yeah
man it was rough because i'm like who
the [ __ ] am i anymore cause like he kept
his
like everything in his life stayed the
same and he was able to go through it
and i'm like wait what i got more ripped
when you're pregnant
you did you were like super lean oh yeah
yeah
i was actually really big before and
then i started getting
uh way more lean when she was getting
pregnant he's like i don't want that
dead bottom it's like the one time you
can't [ __ ]
because when he gets back in a rift i
know i just get the freaking nasty
marshmallow guy the whole time
hey man but look at those biceps though
blood i mean
they're all right yeah but it was hard
and now i think i want to see these past
two years i've been like
nah it's cool like i just gotta find
what makes me me
and i say this is the this is that year
where i'm like oh i'm back
like i feel like myself again oh you
feel like yourself yeah well you think
if you get a second kid
you think you would go through that
whole process again or you think you
already know
who you are yeah so now it's yourself
having the kid rather than transforming
into a mother and losing your identity
yep i mean you seem a little more
experimental
like specifically just looking at you
through your like instagram and your
stories you seem like you're
a little more experimented with what you
wear how you express yourself i was
always like that before though
really yeah i was the one wearing the
weird pants shaving my head getting
tattoos randomly out of nowhere like
i was always that way but you felt like
you turned yourself down around the kid
yeah because i mean i wasn't i wasn't my
size anymore like
my whole body was changing like it was
just i was a different ass
person you know um so yeah like
now i'm like oh god i'm back oh i feel
like myself again
was it stressful for you to feel like
you weren't yourself absolutely dude
absolutely because i mean i've always
lived in a body that
that i'm used to right like i've always
looked the type of way i always felt the
type of way like i only took care of
myself yeah
i didn't have to take care of him i
didn't i wasn't responsible for anyone
else other than myself
and now i mean i didn't grow up with a
bunch of little kids you know i knew i
wanted them
uh and then to go through it and now be
responsible for one and now
i'm i it's not about me anymore you know
everything i was consuming was because
i'm breastfeeding
or because i'm pregnant or i shouldn't
eat that or i shouldn't go here i
shouldn't experience this
parasite in your body exactly it was
literally a parasite you know
um like concerts even i'm like oh it's
gonna be too loud like it's not healthy
for the baby
and now it was so much on the kid i mean
it still is on the kid
but now there's balance and for you i
feel like for you since you've had taika
you're a lot more emotionally expressive
than you were before
i think like from my outside perspective
it seems like you're more comfortable
with showing emotion because you could
show it through this kid and it
expresses in other ways now too i think
so too i think for me
uh growing up like super like buddhist
where you're trying to like shed
yourself from emotion and also just
asian family and also being super
logical
i never had a healthy outlet for
emotions to express them yeah yeah so
it's always been like
you know like if if you want to show
your homie some love it's like hey you
wanna
go slap box a little bit like that
it's like you showed love box yeah it's
like boxing but you don't really have to
punch each other so you just slap
by the way hurts just yeah you just
because it ends up hitting with palm you
start hitting hard
it's just you show love like asian
parents style you know like you don't
hear i made you some food now go [ __ ]
yourself like that's
that's like that kind of love yeah it's
like that kind of love
and i think um when you're dealing with
an adult
even though me and her have been
together for a long time there's still
like the egos at play
because she's her own person i'm my own
person so like
you know like as an adult you you're
kind of scared of completely putting
yourself
out there just because like you're
extremely vulnerable so i never
was able to get like i guess exercise
the tools to fully express myself
but then with tiger is like the purest
thing it's not going to judge me or
anything like that
and i think being able to express that
emotion a hundred percent
i can talk to him as cuny as i want or
as whatever as i want
and i uh once i started to be able to
exercise that i was able to apply that
emotion to other people now
into other parts of my life that's why
at least for me
having a kid really helped me be better
at being emotional
does that does that did that make you
really happy too it's like that this kid
can really bring that side out of him
because he was so hypological
um it was it's interesting that you
picked up on that it happened
with taika because um i always felt like
he was super emotional
like since the beginning because he's
the one that started all that little
cutesy talk
maybe i just didn't even see it for
myself yeah before before him i thought
cute little talk was so stupid
i thought it was so stupid like the most
we'd be cute like i'd be cute in a
relationship was calling them babe
or b like me calling my boyfriend baby
was already too much
no puppy no yeah [ __ ] that stuff man
yeah you know that's the whack dude
y'all like none of that [ __ ]
no we're not gonna yeah
[Laughter]
um i'm like i already have a dad
[ __ ] your babe
yeah uh so like i already felt like he
was a way more emotional than me
it was just when it came to arguments
that that's when it was just different
but
um as we fixed our relationship i felt
like he was already
opening a lot because he would cry
during movies like he would
be like i always cried during movies
though i know but i like i i wasn't used
to that with other guys training day in
300.
you know the exorcist is
yeah no i just felt like he was already
a different person by that point so
um when he was cuny uh with taika it was
already something i had already seen
since the beginning
um yeah i think like maybe i mean that's
a very specific side that he probably
shows you
yes yes yes you know so it's very
particular to you
yes when taika came around is that's
when he started showing that means a lot
more to everybody else
gotcha you know what i mean i was like
oh this guy's a lot more expressive than
he was yeah no he was always like that
yeah so to you you probably got that
side a lot yeah you know what i mean but
for other people i got it too much man
with the point i'm like
you make me feel like it was more
prevalent when tyka was around
because that was like two things
behaving the same way and i'm like
i don't feel like [ __ ] you anymore
because you become like a baby because
you'd be like so cute like that and then
i actually have a real one that's going
to mom i'm hungry or whatever you know
which is my son
and i'm like what the [ __ ] you both
can't be behaving the same way because i
don't want to have sex with you anymore
how would he have to behave then
like a [ __ ] man let me suck you in
your ticket
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] yeah a little bit more of that
yeah so when it comes to like
flirting and engaging you need something
very specific no it can't be the like
hey nope bam
it can't be that way dude i'm telling
you when we first started dating and he
came out with that [ __ ]
i was like oh my gosh is that throwing a
gang signs you better cut that out cuz
no no in the beginning so like i wanted
to be respectful with whatever [ __ ] was
comfortable for him cause like
we were just talking about this today
like when it comes to the sex realm like
i really try to respect
whatever that person's into you know
like um if he came out and was like yo
i love sucking my own dick you know
inside i'm like that's [ __ ] weird but
thank you for sharing that with me
let me see you suck your own dick baby
you know what i mean but poppy is where
she draws alive she goes whoa poppy
though what the [ __ ]
i'm not gonna call anybody but a sucker
your own dick please yeah i'm not doing
it
it's okay uh so like when he came out
with like the little cuny bell talking
it would do with the doubles
you know [ __ ] like that i was like okay
this is [ __ ] weird but i love him so
it's cool like that's just his way to be
flirty mm-hmm just i can't do it anymore
oh no it's like it needs to be balanced
leave it on the podcast and the jokes
and stuff
but if you wanna [ __ ] you better be a
different type of man you better make me
feel like my life's
in danger okay well what are we talking
about yeah squeeze my [ __ ] soul
oh so you need him to so you are like
into macho
macho man yes that's super like yes hey
we [ __ ] know what let's get this and
he just grabs you by the hair and just
suck you in the mouth yeah
thanks babe yeah i want to feel like i'm
in like some sort of like
he can he can i can lose my life tonight
i'm like yeah oh my god it's like okay
that's crazy that sounds exciting say no
stop all the way through
that sounds extreme but it's not like
it's more sensual but i'm just obviously
painting
the gun and i caress
you feeling dangerous
let me get that you're gonna stick this
clock in your [ __ ]
it's not like that it's not like that so
what's your thing then
do you need anything specific from her
um
i think for me because like you know
when i get consumed in emotion i i'm in
that state
so as long as we're good um
she's just sexy so it's easy for you
it's easy yeah it's uh it was true it
was before
where like when we would have huge dry
spells it was because we're going
through that really volatile phase
where i'm pissing her off she's pissing
me off and then if she pisses me off
then i just want to kill her so we don't
have sex for like a whole month
you know the regular [ __ ] you know if i
could murder her so it's really
different yeah i feel like it's easier
for guys right like the girl just shows
up naked and we're like
ready to go yeah let's just do it yeah
and i always like equate like women to
like uh
like a [ __ ] 1982 honda accord yeah
there's like a specific way to jingle
the bucket you turn it three times like
90 degrees like turn the heater down
with the signal left
i wish we weren't like that like i wish
we weren't but that's just how we're
built
so you you need specific cues and you
can't just be like okay
especially now man like i'm so exhausted
like
before taika it was like oh my god like
i was always [ __ ] horny always ready
to go but after taika
bro it's [ __ ] hard i'm exhausted
right yeah and i've been taking care of
this kid and giving him my all right
all of it you know so then now it's like
me time and i'm like finally i can like
be an adult and now i have to like now
he's turned on and i'm like
oh so it's like oh [ __ ] after tycho's
thing's taking over then it's my time
yeah then it's us time so yeah yes
that's rough she's exhausted i mean i'm
exhausted too so like when we put tycho
to sleep
sometimes we just go on the couch or our
bed and we're just there
yeah either on our phone for like 30
minutes or whatever and then we're like
hey you wanna watch something
and then it's like us time i never
understood when um
i guess it's not for me because people
told me that when they work out
like with uh lift weights they get
hornier
yeah that's true i'm the opposite really
when i work out do activities
my sex drive is all the way down because
i give it all
into the workout or kickboxing and so
afterwards like for sure if i'm
kickboxing consistently
your boy has never will never be horny
i'm too tired i'm too tired to be honest
i'm exhausted i'm done does marielle go
you better stop kickboxing we need to
have sex
well mary i don't think mariel is a
hypersexual person she'll go
she'll go with the flow of things so
it's like if i'm exhausted i'm exhausted
and she's sleeping all the [ __ ] time
too so it kind of works out in that
sense but
nice because i was way hornier when i
was fatter i think because i wasn't
watching
so it's like the activity was sex yeah
but now that i'm
always active i'm biking 30 miles 20
miles it's like oh
i'm tired oh yeah interesting which
sucks for her
you know it's like it's like oh it's the
opposite you know i think like cardio
things is kind of like that
like if i'm lifting weights um i do
think i get horny i don't know what it
is i don't know if it like boosts
testosterone or something
yeah but when i was training for the
marathon i don't remember being very
horny
i just wanted to sleep yeah cause i
would be running like 10 15 like 19
miles
and i don't think i was very horny after
that time because she noticed
like i would grope her less yeah when
i'm when i'm working out
like i'm just sleeping she goes watch
he's gonna try and have sex with me
tonight and i'm just
oh it's like that oh you're just tired
now
well now you're mr sleepy look at all
this [ __ ]
oh no no no she's great i just get tired
like i can't i
especially when i'm sore sex is off the
table there is no sore sex
i cannot do it really no i'm too sore it
hurts
it's [ __ ] painful dog when i worked
out with him at barbell we didn't have
sex for
eight months [ __ ] i'm sorry sorry mario
that's [ __ ] if i'm getting hurt man what
happened that one other day we're having
sex and i had like a my hamstring
started
cramping that's hilarious i forgot what
what wait what was it
when did we stop yeah
i don't know what are you trying to get
it no no i just forgot oh that is yours
i was thinking about the [ __ ] dude
that's what it is the soreness and like
the it prevents you from [ __ ] i was
like oh [ __ ] what happened
i don't remember a tweaked hip or
something do you guys have to find like
specific times because obviously i don't
have a kid now right so it's like
do you have to find specific times of
schedule or is it still spur of the
moment
no it's not for the moment it's
definitely when he's asleep for sure
he's just
after ty is asleep yeah after or before
after okay yeah before i don't know we
don't do morning sex
and we also have very different
schedules well i'm not very different
but he'll like leave like at six
and then tyka wakes up by 7 30. up in
the morning dude that's great yeah we
wake up early and then recently
we've been like waking up at four so
that ain't happening
[ __ ] all that damn and i'm the most
horny during the day
and you are too or an afternoon so i
feel like once tyka goes to school
it's all baby you've watched well i mean
this house smells funny
yeah when it's when he's five baby we're
[ __ ] everywhere
yeah so everywhere i know right it's
like so we say that you guys are just
back on the couch
oh this feels good to be just chilling
because we know at three o'clock and get
off from school
it's gonna be over i mean that's what
schooling is it's really free daycare
yeah it is you know get the [ __ ] out of
here let us be like humans again
let us [ __ ] on the kitchen please on the
[ __ ] kitchen counter
were you guys pretty experimental when
you guys had sex prior to taika like you
guys were
not very mundane sex people like in
terms of just like
no no i think cuz like so
i think because he was pretty sheltered
in that sex area
like there's a lot of stuff that we're
still experimenting that he's still kind
of learning about
like missionary this sounds interesting
no i don't know it wasn't like that
vanilla you know
but like i think because i had so many
like moves that i was down to do that he
would
like almost bust kickboxing
[Laughter]
have you heard of the pretzel dmt kimura
like what the [ __ ] is this
so it was like i had to i had to like
reveal all my tips and tricks
very slowly are you gonna break him oh
well that or like he's just gonna bust
and then we're done you know so like
so we're still like we're still working
it all out oh my god the place is so
good if i if i do too fast you're gonna
come too fast
okay bart you tell them what i mean you
said everything
i know he's making it sound like i'm
blowing my own
you [ __ ] liar why do you want us to
break up so bad this whole
podcast you've just turned us against
each other no i'm just saying i just
i just like giving you [ __ ] yeah that's
so [ __ ] funny
i told you one time right like uh before
we got together i saw him having sex
with another girl
no i forgot about that holy [ __ ] i
saw him [ __ ] another girl yeah that's
long time so i was with
so i was with my boyfriend and then he
was seeing some chick
and then we went to the beach late at
night and then um like we went
separate ways like me and my boyfriend
were doing our thing
and then i forgot i had to get something
and our bags were where they were
so i just went back and i'm like in my
underwear like we're like naked we
weren't planning on going to the beach
so i'm like in my underwear and i go get
it and like the chick is on top of him
and they're like having sex and i'm like
oh [ __ ] my bad oh it was i don't know
and i was like
oh [ __ ] and i'm like i left because i
didn't know we were going to be together
so i'm like yeah bart's getting it
oh wow a hard haul oh that's crazy i
forgot about that memory
whoa i'll never [ __ ] lie this gotta
be like
2016 yeah you literally saw your husband
have sex with another person
i mean he saw me be in a relationship
with another person like the whole thing
that's crazy but i did see a map did you
ever you never saw us do anything
never yeah whoa that's [ __ ] weird
dude that's
trippy it was and i saw the way they
were doing it and i'm like
she whack oh okay i did i didn't know
it was like that's what i tell myself so
i can get through it okay
okay you're like [ __ ] left or a
post-it note next time try this
no that's what i just tell myself oh my
that's crazy i don't think i've ever
heard anybody going through that have
seen
that's kind of a brain [ __ ] for me it is
right i don't think i could
ever i don't know if i could move people
it's a different it's a different time
so like in my mind it's just homie bart
oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah that makes sense i had no feelings
for him so there was nothing
like i had no no feeling about it other
than like yeah
boy you know what i mean like just like
seeing my homie get hooked up with that
i'm like [ __ ] yeah
my homie's getting serviced wow and you
called it serviced
you know what i mean like getting a
service he's getting his oil changed you
know so i was like happy for him but
like
looking back at it it's [ __ ] weird
but like that's really weird yeah i
don't have a thing
with it though like i'm just like i
completely forgot about that i'll never
[ __ ] forget do you remember her
actually
like seeing it like oh [ __ ] i don't
think so well i was having sex so i
don't remember
i think my [ __ ] i was focused you
just look at the titties like okay this
is what's going on right now nice nice
nice nice
yeah i was like i went i'm like oh [ __ ]
oh my bad
just like went back probably the only
the weird i've ever seen
walking in on somebody have sex was well
this is kind of weird because
one of your homies have no it was it was
a home girl
we were at a party and these dudes were
running a train on her
oh wait what and then the next the
like a few years later my friend he was
like i want you to meet my fiance
and it was the girl oh damn that i saw
at the party
getting a train rant on her dude what
does that look like were there just a
line of dudes they were doing uh what do
you call spit roasting her ass
what does that mean dick in the mouth
and some do hitting it in the back you
saw that it was at a house party
you saw it and i was like what the [ __ ]
and she was
into it and i was like yo and then we
were having we still haven't told them
until this day
because of how like in love he is with
her and he's like talking about it like
yo
like yeah she's like the sweet because
he was with a lot of hood rats before oh
and so when he was talking
it doesn't sound like it changed that's
what i'm saying so i was like dude she's
like the sweetest girl and what he told
us which kind of broke her heart it was
like
she's actually a virgin oh my god oh you
have to tell him
they're married and they have two kids
now so i you know what i mean it is what
it is
they're happy i'm not going to go ahead
and yeah yeah yeah no i thought it was
like but it's like bro i legit saw like
[ __ ] three dudes run a train on her
so it's like don't know
she was [ __ ] loose though like i'm
surprised he doesn't [ __ ] know that
because we all she kind of has a
reputation
of kind of being that person but i don't
know why he's never
ever asked or like connected the two
because it's not like she looks like
she's one of those like sweet sweet
girls she looks like an abg
oh you know what i'm saying yeah so i
remember when i
because we actually and i actually went
to the same elementary school so she
knows who i
am right she goes oh my god i haven't
seen you in so long i was like i know
more about you than you actually think i
do
damn that she had a reputation for
[ __ ] around a lot so but that's kind
of weird that was like one of those like
that's weird yeah yeah yeah and then the
homies kind of texted just like yo you
know who he's with right i'm like yeah
dude what the [ __ ]
i was like he's in love with her but
they're married they have two kids so
hey is what it is it is winning i
thought she was a [ __ ] virgin
when he met her well hopefully the truth
all came out and you just didn't know
about it he's a really sweet guy i think
he's just happy to be with the girl
honestly if i look i mean this is me
being presumptuous but
uh he i think she is his like first real
serious serious girlfriend
so for him she can do no no wrong
anyways if we told him
what her prior past was it would wreck
his uh idea of who she is
so whatever secret that they're having
they're happy we're gonna leave it alone
yeah so we never we never said anything
maybe one day she'll
break it to him too that's what i'm
saying when she feels comfortable that
they're comfortable enough she'll let
him know maybe he already knows maybe i
i don't i
he does not know for sure a hundred
percent that would wreck him that boy is
brittle as [ __ ]
oh no no no no so he's you know you ever
meet somebody who's like
who believes that there was somebody
that they don't deserve
oh he kind of like idolizes her a little
bit wow
and that's the type of guy that she
needs though she wants to feel like
she's a princess that she's put up on
this pedestal
so they kind of work out and i honestly
think that they have a great relation
from what i see from an exterior
yeah but we've never i mean why would we
tell her like sometimes the truth
doesn't really help their relationship
it doesn't and it shouldn't be your
place at that point exactly so we just
leave it i just saw that he's happy
like if she was [ __ ] around with
somebody then i'd be like hey
by the way she's had 36 people inside
that [ __ ] oh my god
you know then i would mention it but
she's been faithful he's also pretty
well off
so it works out you know she knew that
she knew that her [ __ ] probably had some
mileage
and she's like i need to find a good guy
and she found the sweetest dude
yeah he just doesn't know about the past
that's all damn damn
i hope he never finds out oh if if he
finds out he's going to give us a call
he's going to be like
drunk out of his mind pissed breaking
[ __ ] were they from the same
neighborhood or same community or same
circle of friends
no that's crazy well i could understand
because he moved into
our area from uh the bay
to sacramento uh when he was like 15.
so he doesn't know too much about the
people
like that so his information of what he
has about people yeah is a little bit
late so unless somebody voluntarily told
him about who
who she is because he met her in college
after they both left sacramento
so he didn't actually they didn't go to
the same high school or anything because
she was in a different part of
so when they met up in college i was
like oh they went to the same college
together but they're both from the same
hometown
and then but we know about her past like
legit past oh my gosh
and it wasn't even like that far few and
far between it was like a high school
party when she was like 17. oh my god
yeah cause we were you know we would
have these house parties and we would
see stuff and you know
ghosts were hoeing around they would
haul around they would like [ __ ] give
people head or whatever what not yeah
she was notorious so i literally
remember we walked i walked up and we
kind of peek into a door and we see this
girl getting a train right on her and
we're like oh [ __ ]
that's pretty tight and then as a young
person
right like yo that's [ __ ] dope and we
walk away and i'm like what the [ __ ]
that's her
she really likes the taste of penis i
guess i guess she was a freak
it was one of those girls to remember i
was talking about those like hyper
catholic girls yeah
so she was trying to do the antithesis
of what her parents want out of her yeah
and i think for him i don't know this
exactly but i'm pretty sure he knows
that his her parents are missionaries
you know so she's like this holier than
now girl but she really isn't
she's almost like the daughter version
of a pastor's kid yes
exactly so you know like um i'm not sure
if you've ever been around these type of
girls
that were like super hyper religious
better not be
here let me hear you but they were like
these super their families were super
hyper religious so they would do the
exact opposite
and these like girls who never grew up
in the hood never had ghetto friends but
would always [ __ ] [ __ ] gangbangers
and date like oh yeah
yeah she was one of those girls oh i see
yeah damn
that's some [ __ ] i'm telling you i mean
hey kudos to all those tricks that got
it in though
because then it's like you know what you
like you know what you don't like so
yeah
she's not somebody good he's he's
balling you see because she got enough
dick to know which one's worth it and
which one's not
i don't even know i'm pretty [ __ ] up
what are you talking about right right
here this guy around her man i know but
i needed someone that was balling you
know
owner of barbell brigade you [ __ ] the
single owner of this
barber
when you do it anyways
i know i'm like [ __ ] it didn't work out
how i thought it would well guys
that wraps up this episode of the genius
brain podcast
we got the uh uh
what is it called the schneider spider
yeah i honestly don't even know i think
it's snyder's right snyder's honey honey
mitchell petrols honey mustard
delicious we got wuhan quan and snyder's
[ __ ] geo here
oh my god you can follow them on all of
their handles do you go wait is your
actual g
is it geoantoinette do you underscore
antoinette geo underscore everything
and then just straight bar quan yeah
just the one and only there's no other
chinese person named bart ever as well
no not true not even bartholomew it's
barton
yeah yeah yeah barton
genius brain every thursdays and sundays
and we will see you all next time baby
peace